has anyone seen representative Murray
okay oh oh wa no I misplaced you he he
told me that no that empty seat who's
MPC who is
late so this will change on your sheet
Maguire offered an amendment so it's to
amend here yep and I've got the
amendment here okay how's that bar doing
all right you ready
nope the way there's a big
amended here just
just this my copy or is that your copy I
don't know you flipping them M off you
so
trying to figure out what what they did
was they
retain and then they didn't do anything
with it where the hell he at yeah so
it Tracy
us yeah I did that
last who's the empty SE oh that's Tracy
he's he's around he's looking into
problem I just pointed out to you all
right we'll wait for him to get
is you have two
two good morning we'll call the finance
committee to
order we have a uh a large number of
bills to deal deal with today for their
final we hope um
disposition there are um 25 out of the
33 that have been Incorporated in
hb2 um don't worry about making the
motion if it's an expedient because it
has been Incorporated because even if
you don't hand something to to uh Janet
I've already told her what to say if
it's going to be incorporated in hp2 no
further action
necessary
and so on so we'll begin with division
one and call upon
representative Lehman to tell us who's
going to make the Motions on each
bill thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman a good morning let the repres
uh recognize representative Griffin to
212 Mr
ation was
ined
H2 358
365 and is no longer
needed thank you there any further
discussion we'll try to get through
these 25 as quickly as possible the
motion is inexpedient to legislate the
clerk will call the role on that motion
on House Bill
212 thank you Mr
chairman uh the
yeah representative Earth yes
representative Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative
Mooney
yes representative uh kofalt for
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes represent
restive hle yes representative Sweeney
yes representative Camrose yes the
option representative p v Muller yes
representative
walner
yes represent norren yes representative
Lehman yes representative buo yes
representative huitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative eil yes
representative
torski representative Shapiro let let me
Begin by saying representative Shapiro
is replacing representative tersi
representative kofalt is replacing
representative
Edwards welcome thank you yes thank
you president haken Phillips yes
president Stringham
yes and representative Wier
yes got representative
v he's probably
there let's
see hat hatch no hatch hatch is off the
list all right so let's Okay so very
easily representative
you so on the on the future roll calls
you're going to be put in going to be
adding him if he's not there already
you're going to be adding Shapiro for
tersi and kofalt for Edwards we're going
to try sir we'll do our best give them
time all right and the announcement is
and the announce and the announcement is
uh the vote is 25 to Z in favor of the
motion of itl thank you and I think this
Cal representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman uh House
Bill 230 Department of Agriculture
markets and food and electronic data
processing system like the recognized
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman I move House Bill 230 in
expedient to
legislate we includeed in the
second all right second who was your
second it ought to be somebody from
division one second there we go
okay all
right further discussion on House Bill
230 seeing none you're ready for the
question the clerk will call the role on
the motion to make House Bill 230 230
inexpedient to
legislate
okay representative Earth yes yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
yes representative Bean yes resent of
hle yes resent of Sweeney yes resent of
camell yes resent of Poa vich Muller yes
representative
walner yes represent nor
yes representative Lehman yes
representative buo yes representative
huitt yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
Evel
yeah Shapiro Shapiro
yes nice try try to remember
sorry representative haen Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative
grassy
yes and representative wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 25 to Z in
favor of the itl thank you we put that
on the
consent without objection 23
representative Lehman's
recognized thank you Mr chairman 276 six
establishing a cob bacteria mitigation
Grant fund like to recognize
representative Maguire and
eel and thank you Mr chairman I I um
move itl on this
bill so we put this in House Bill two
for a dollar and the sponsor
representative rung talked the Senate
into a million and that's where it
stands
now is there further discussion on on
House Bill
276 seeing none the clerk will call a
rooll on the motion to Mark the bill
legislate got you make the corrections
on those tersi right Shapiro and and for
we'll do the best we can Edwards right
Kofa all right U representative Earth
yes represent Maguire yes represent
Petri votes yes represent emmer yes
representative Griffin yes
yes represent Bean yes represent
hle yes represent Sweeney yes
representative Campell yes represent
papichi Muller yes representative
walner yes represent Oren yes represent
Lehman yes represent buo yes
representative hwit yes representative
yes right not yet representative evil
yes now representative Shapiro
yes represent haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent grassy
yes
and representative uh wer yes Mr
chairman the vote is 25 to Z in favor of
the
itl vote being 25 to Z with no objection
I'll put it on the consent
calendar represent LE thank you Mr
chairman House Bill 300 prohibiting the
disposal of certain food waste like to
recognize representative eel and
Maguire um thank you uh
chair leean um I move itl on
hb300 thank you um uh hb300 which would
require um the diversion of food waste
under specified circumstances and
provided for the hiring of a Dees uh
employee to
oversee composting program was included
in total in the budget and therefore is
no longer necessary
thank you for sending me your your
300 don't need to record
that was that vote
again further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call a rooll on the motion to
uh Mark House Bill 300 as inexpedient to
legislate thank you Mr chairman uh
representative ver yes represent Maguire
yes representative Petri Vol yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative money yes
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes represent Sweeney
yes representative camell yes represent
papovich Muller yes represent
walner yes representative norren yes
representative leechman yes
buo
yes representative uitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative eel yes
representative
Shiro representative hien Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes represent
grassy
yes and representative Wilder yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to Z in favor of
the
itl motion being 25 to Z on H 300 I'll
ask that it be put in the consent
calendar representative leean thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 311 appropriation
for eligible Wastewater projects like to
recognize representative grassy and
Sweeny Mr chairman I'll move
itl Motion in a second to itl Is there
further discussion seeing none I'm sorry
Mr chairman I missed that
second Mr SW thank you representative
swe thank
you all right the clerk will call the
role on the motion to Mark House Bill
311 inexpedient to
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes representa
Petri votes yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative
Mooney yes
yes representative Bean yes represent
hle yes represent Sweeney yes repr
camell yes represent papovich Muller yes
representative walner yes representative
noran yes representative Lehman yes
representative buo yes representative HT
yes representative Heath yes
representative Mur yes representative
yes represent haen Phillips yes
yes and representative wer yes Mr chair
the vote is 25 to Z to
itl the vote being 25 to Z I will ask it
to be put on the consent calendar for
House Bill 311 representative lean thank
you Mr chairman
347 establishing a superior land use
review docket like to recognize
representative eel and
cells um thank you very much um I move
itl on HB
347 I will second that motion um as with
uh the previous bills this bill uh
regarding the creation of a superior
court land use rev review docket has
been included in the budget and is no
longer
needed motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 347 is there any
further discussion seeing none the clerk
will call a role on the motion to
inexpedient to
legislate thank Bill 347 thank you Mr
chairman uh representative F yes
represent Maguire yes representative
Petri vote Yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofalt
yes representative Bean yes represent of
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbell yes represent
papichi merer yes representative walner
yes representative norren yes
representative Lehman yes
representative buo yes representative
hwit yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
eel yes representative Shapiro yes
representative haaken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative grassy
yes and representative wer yes Mr chair
the vote is 25 to Zer in favor of the
itl the vote being 25 to Zer on the
motion to any expedience to legislate
I'll ask it to be put on the consent
calendar represent lean thank you Mr
chairman House Bill
436 actually there'll be an amendment
offered by representative Maguire that
will uh be spoken on right now thank you
Mr chairman I I'd like to move Amendment
2458 H and I'd like to speak to my
motion I'll second it Mr chairman okay
you are recognized thank you so um House
Bill fourth 36 was you may remember it
was the for um improving group to
require retirement plan for what we call
the Gap people it's the people whose uh
plan was um 12 years ago was was
reduced um and so this was strongly
supported by the house we put it into
House Bill 2 um it was just as strongly
disliked by the Senate it and what they
did in the end of the day was created a
commission to study the problem and that
commission has just finished with a
recommendation not very not particularly
close it was 8 to well I mean not
particularly strongly it was 8 to six
but but they they did have a
recommendation to do a partial version
of of House Bill
436 now that's going to become a bill uh
that um repres representative leean will
be the prime sponsor I'll be a
co-sponsor and hopefully others and but
it will it'll be handled like a normal
bill this coming year in the Edna
committee um so that leaves 436 with
nothing with no particular purpose and
so one of the things that happened in
the budget that that particularly
annoyed me if you remember house bill 50
was the bill that
um on the house floor we changed to pay
down the unfunded liability by $50
million and then we tabled it and put it
in the budget well that was also just
simply removed by the Senate and so this
amendment would turn House Bill 436 into
that version of H of house bill 50 that
was strongly passed by the house so it
would pay down the unfunded liability by
$50 million
um and um personally I think this is
very you know it's a financially it's a
good thing to do
um the unfunded liability is like debt
that's ACR at
6.75% interest and so for every dollar
we put in today that's like a do7 we
don't have to put in a year from now or
a11 14 we don't have to put in a year
from then and so on and and so um I
believe we have extra money that was
unspent during the budget period And
this is a way of sort of having a mini
mini Committee of conference with the
Senate and say look we really want this
and so um that's that's my
proposal so the the motion is not to
pass as amended by well I think 2458 Mr
chairman we probably should have passed
the amendment first or vote on it
hopefully pass it and then
separ see a show of hands on who was in
favor of adopting Amendment
2458 raise your hands if you're in
favor one two three four five six seven
eight nine
12 I think it's 14 or 15 those
opposed
one two three four five six seven 18 and
seven 18 to seven
amendment if I could Mr chairman the
vote in the division to support the
Maguire amendment was four to one
okay further discussion anybody want to
say why they're opposed they just let it
go any further discussion see
none um we have adopted Amendment 2458
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended House Bill 436 which by the way
has been thank you zeroed out and
replaced with the with the text of 2458
2458 replaces the whole bill which was
several pages so the clerk will call a
roll on the motion of ought to pass as
chairman
436 all right representative Earth
yes representative Maguire yes represent
Petri votes yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofalt yes representative Bean yes
represent hle
yes represent Sweeny yes represent
camell yes repres representative
papovich meller yes Representative
walner
no Representative noran no
representative Lehman
no represent uitt
yes represent Heath
no representative Murray
no representative evil no represent
representative Shapiro no representative
haen Phillips
no representative Stringham
yes representative grassie
yes I show 17 to8 that is correct Mr
chairman 17 to8 okay and this will not
go on consent the vote is 17 to8 for
House Bill 436 ought to pass says
amended with amendment number
2458 representative
lman thank you Mr chairman House Bill
462 making an appropriation to the solid
waste management fund like to recognize
representative eel and
Maguire um thank you sir um I move itl
on HB
second um HB 462 would have um
appropriated $2 million to the solid
waste management fund to help fund a
grant program for solid waste diversion
activities and also Target food waste
reduction when it was rolled into the
budget when it got to the Senate they
reduced it to a million dollar um so it
is in the budget at half the amount we
originally supported and for that reason
this bill is no longer needed and I'm
moving
itl motion of an expedient on House Bill
462 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the rooll on the motion to Mark
House Bill 462 inexpedient to legis
thank you Mr chairman representative F
yes represent Maguire yes representative
Petri vs representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representa
kall yes represent of bean yes represent
of hle yes represent Sweeny yes
represent of cell yes POA M yes
represent
walner yes resent norgan yes
representative Lehman yes representative
buo yes representative huitt
yes representative uh Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
Shapiro the updated list isn't updated
okay that's all right hen representative
hen Phillips yes representative
Stringham
yes represent grassie
yes and what the heck happened
here come out him and call me yet I
know but there should be 25 where did I
miss oh I see
writing Mr chair the vote is 25 to Zer
vote being 25 to Zer ask that the bill
be put on consent representative lman
thank you Mr chairman House Bill 571
relative to the cost of living
adjustments for certain group two
retirees like to represent uh recognize
representative cambrell and
Griffin thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion to itl House Bill 571
second it the reason we were it it
alling this bill is because a provision
uh for a one time a $500 allowance was
already made in sections 368 through 370
of hb2 so this bill is no longer
necessary motion to Mark House Bill 571
inexpedient to legislate is there any
further discussion seeing none the clerk
will call the role on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate for House Bill
571 and I assume uh representative
Griffin second to that motion thank
see
71 representative F yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin
yes representative Mooney yes represent
Kofa
yes repr Bean yes represent hle yes
repres Sweeney yes represent camell yes
repres papichi Muller yes representative
walner yes repres noren
yes I'm sorry I
I thank you representative leechman yes
representative Buco yes representative
hwit
yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
yes represent hien Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes representative
grassie yes representative wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to0 to itl
motion motion being 25 to Z on House
Bill 571 will recommend the consent
calendar representative Lehman thank you
Mr chairman Senate Bill 128 relative to
payments for legal services for persons
involuntary admitted I'd like to
represent uh recognize representative
Sweeney and
cells thank you Mr chairman I I do move
in expedient to legislate on Senate Bill
128 uh unlike the other bills that we've
already dealt with so far in committee
today uh this bill did not enter into
the budget uh however it was a Senate
bill that came to us from the Senate
when it came to division one we didn't
hear anything from the Senate as to the
importance of the bill or as to why we
needed to fund this program they did not
see fit uh to fund it in their version
of the budget which they had the final
say on um so for that reason we we could
not find reason to support an additional
expenditure after the budget process was
concluded on a on the Senate bill so
that's why we're moving in expedient to
motion Senate Bill 128 the motion is
inexpedient to legislate
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role on the motion to inexpedient
to legislate for Senate Bill 128 thank
you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Gamal
yes represent Popovich Muller yes
represent walner yes representative
norren yes representative Lehman yes
representative Buco yes representative
HT yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
eel yes representative Shapiro yes
representative haen Phillips yes
representative ringham yes
representative grassy yes representa
Wier yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z to
itl
motion no motion on Senate Bill 128
being 25 to Z on itl I will recommend
the consent calendar for that
representative leean thank you Mr
chairman Senate Bill
267 requiring the commissioner of the
Department of U Environmental Services
to consider a cumulative impact analysis
like to recognize representative Sweeney
and
cells thank you Mr chairman I move uh in
expedient to legislate on Senate Bill
267 uh similar to Senate Bill 128 this
was a Senate bill that got through the
Senate came to the house and was not
included in the Senate's version of the
final budget uh for for funding purposes
uh however separately from 128 we did
have the Senate uh who sponsored it came
into our committee we had a thorough
discussion on the policy uh we could
could probably spend among our committee
today hours discussing the policy of
cumulative impact analysis and the road
map for that and the potential path that
that would take the state down towards
uh but so solely on the financial
matters this would hire an additional
staffer in the Department of
Environmental Services to build this
program out and to study the potential
definition of cumulative impact analysis
uh post budget adding an additional
staffer uh in my opinion is not a wise
move for us to make uh especially when
there were other vacancies in the
department uh of Staff positions similar
to this nature uh and for that reason on
the financial side of things I would
move inexpedient to legislate and I will
second that motion motion to Market
inexpedient to legislate Motion in a
second Is there further discussion on
Senate Bill
267 representative eel thank you very
much Mr chairman um uh representative uh
Sweeney has accurately
uh described the situation with respect
to the policy part of the bill um I
would remind the committee that from a
policy standpoint there was very strong
support um on the house floor the bill
was unanimously recommended by the house
environment and agriculture committee we
passed it 302 to
77 um this would indeed uh create a
position in Dees to review um what there
is in existence under New Hampshire law
to look at cumulative impacts um but
also look uh more broadly at the at the
issue the cost to the um budget would be
$250,000 for two years as estimated by
the um by the department I want to
emphasize this does not authorize Dees
to take any action it is only
authorizing Dees to make a
recommendation to the legislature and we
could decide uh in the future what we
wanted to do I think the point here is
that uh under existing law any uh
facility that is um being analyzed for
the pollutants that it is emitting is
looking is being looked at in a siloed
approach therefore uh there could be a
great deal of say air pollution
generally um and and that aspect isn't
even looked at they're only looking at
this point at permitting the individual
facility um I just considering for
instance what happened with st gobain p
uh there's any number of environmental
toxins out there um I would say that
looking at things at such a siloed
approach is not good for the public
health uh for Citizens for the State of
New Hampshire and for that reason I urge
my colleagues to oppose the itl and
support an alternative motion thank you
thank you further discussion on Senate
Bill
267 seeing none the clerk will call a
role on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate for Senate Bill
267 thank you Miss excuse me thank you
Mr chairman represent of Earth yes
represent of Maguire yes representative
Petri Vol yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin
yes representative Mooney yes represent
of kofalt yes represent of bean yes
represent of hle yes represent of
Sweeney yes represent of cell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
Representative walner
no Representative noren no
representative Lehman
no representative bu
no Representative uitt no representative
Heath
no representative Murray no
representative evil no representative
Shapiro no represent representative hen
Phillips
no representative Stringham
no representative grassy
no representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 13-2 in
favor of the
itl the vote being 13-2 we'll put this
on the regular calendar as inexpedient
to legislate thank you division
one moving on to division two
recognizing representative
emmer thank you Mr chairman HP 272 I
recognize representative
Heath thank you Mr chair um I would like
to um
move House Bill
272 um as itl our vote in uh
subcommittee was 9 to Z and this is been
put into the
budget I'll second that
motion further discussion on the motion
of inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill
272 seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the role of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
272 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative
Mooney yes representative kofol yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeny yes
representative camell yes representative
papichi Muller yes represent
walner
yes represent noren yes
representative Lehman yes represent buo
yes representative huitt yes
representative Heath
yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
Shapiro yes represent haen Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent
grassy yes representative wer yes Mr
chairman the vote is 25 toer to itl
motion motion being 25 um the vote being
25 to Zer on the motion inexpedient to
legislate for House Bill 272 I will Mark
that down for the consent calendar
represent representative Emer thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 419 recognize
representative Petri and representative
Heath did you skip
332 i s I'm sorry HB 322 332 332 I'm
having a tough day today
uh relative to school building Aid
eligible
projects I would recognize
representative Petri and representative
Heath okay make a motion to it
Allis and I'll
second Heath motion for inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 332 is there any
further discussion seeing none the clerk
will call a role for the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
itl thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
yes representative Bean yes represent
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes represent
papovich Muller yes represent
walner
yes represent Oren yes represent
leishman yes representative buo yes
representative uitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
Shiro
yes representative hen Phillips yes
represent string
yes represent grassy yes represent wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z to itl
a motion the vote being 25 to zero on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
the house bill 332 I will report that
for the consent calendar representative
Emer thank you Mr chairman House Bill
419 I recognize representative
Petri 419
yes Mr chairman I move uh house bill
itl is there a
second thank you I second Motion in a
second on the motion of itl for House
Bill 419 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role for inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 419 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes represent
McGuire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofalt yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeney representative V Kim Bros yes
representative Popovich Muller
yes representative
walner yes representative noran yes
representative Lehman yes represent buo
yes representative uitt yes
representative Heath yes represent
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative hicken Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes represent
grassie yes representative Wier yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to Z to I the vote
being 25 to Zer on the motion of anying
spe to legislate on House Bill 419 I
will report it out is for the consent
calendar representative Emer thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 42 recognized
representative Petri
representative thank you Mr uh Mr chair
Mr chair
chair uh I move the motion itl and I
will second it 420 HB
420 a motion of inexpedient to legislate
and a second on House Bill 420 is there
any further discussion seeing none are
you ready for the question the clerk
will call a role of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
okay representative Earth yes
representative uh Maguire yes
representative Petri vots yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kof yes representative
Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes rep
representative uh camell yes rep
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative walner
yes representative noron yes
representative Lehman
yes representative buo yes
representative uitt yes representative
Heath
yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
supero yes representative haen Phillips
yes representative
Stringham representative grassy yes
representative Wier yes Mr chair the
vote is 25 to Z to itl motion the vote
being 25 to Z on the itl motion for
House Bill 420 we will report it for the
consent
calendar representative
Emer House Bill
468 uh you have a copy of the bill at
your workstation and there's also an
amendment uh the uh committee voted
unanimous on
468 but we did want to amend it we
amended the date the effective dates
because we'd already passed July 1 of
2023 and also the completion date and we
also added in paragraph one Roman Roman
numeral 3 in consultation with the
attorney general was added to the
language of the original Bill other than
that the intent and the and the purpose
is intact so I would move uh uh
Amendment
2023 2294
H I'll second that a motion to accept
House Bill a correction to accept
Amendment 2294 for House Bill 468 if
you're in favor of the amendment please
hand looks unanimous hands down any
opposed Mo the uh amendment is adopted
amended motion to ex
uh recommend House Bill 468 as amended
ought to pass as amended second was
second Murray CL will call the rooll on
the motion of ought to pass as amended
with Amendment
2294 on House Bill
294 thank you Mr chairman representative
IR yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative pole yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
Camrose yes
representa Popovich merer yes
representative
walner
yes represent Oren yes representative
leichman yes representative buo
yes represent uitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
Shapiro yes representative haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
wer yes Mr chair the
motion P ought to pass as amended is 25
to Zer okay and 25 to zero and due to
the fact that it appropriates some money
we put this on the regular
calendar representative Emer thank you
Mr chairman HB 521 recognize
representative
Petri representative
you got a lot of these Joe for some
that uh let me see
521 I moveed 521 itl I believe second
budget repres second it and he second it
okay okay is there any further
discussion on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate the house bill
521 seeing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion of in expedience to
legislate for House Bill
521 sorry about that I'm busy a little
busy at the
time thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative caml yes representative
uh Popovich meller yes representative
walner yes representative norg yes
representative Lehman yes representative
buo yes representative huitt
yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
yes represent haaken Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes representa
grassy yes representative wer yes Mr
chair the motion to itl is 25 to Z
motion for itl on House Bill for 21
being 25 to Z I will recommend it for
the consent calendar representative
Emory was that was 521
521 521 okay okay we got
it I'll give you a second Joe uh I'm
good house bill 529 recognized
representative Petri and representative
I and I will second um House Bill
529 motion on House Bill 529 is
inexpedient to legislate is there any
further discussion seeing none clerk
will call a rooll for the motion of
inexpedient to legisl on House Bill
529 thank you Mr chairman okay
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
uh kofalt yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative cell yes
representative papichi meller yes
representative
walner yes represent Oran yes represent
Lehman yes representative buo yes
representative uitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
Shapiro yes representative Hawkin
Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes yes
represent grassy yes representa wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z to it
motion the vote being 25 to Zer on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 529 I will recommend consent
calendar representative Emer thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 540 recognize
representative P3 and representative
P
I recommend
itl and I will second house bill 540
Motion in a second to Mark House Bill
540 as inexpedient to legislate is there
any
further any further
discussion I see a light on down there
oh okay uh
oh seeing none the clerk will call a
rooll for the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 540 FNL 540 I e
l thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri VES yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative Hull yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
papovich Muller yes representative uh
walner
yes representative Oren yes
representative Lehman yes representative
buo yes representative uitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative eel yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative haaken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z to
itl
motion 540 the vote being 25 to Z on the
motion to inexpedient legislate for
540 I will recommend the consent
calendar representative Emer thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 541 I recognize
Heath 541 yes Mr chair I move 541
inexpedient to legislates and I second
HB
541 motion of inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill
541 is there any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call a role
for any expedient to legislate on House
Bill
541 thank you Mr chairman uh
representative ER
yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri vots yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representa
Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
poov Muller yes representative walner
yes representative norran yes
representative Lehman yes representative
Buco yes representative huitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative eel yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative haaken Phillips yes
representative
Stringham representative grassy yes
representative wer yes Mr chair the vote
is 25 to Z to itl a motion
541 the motion uh the vote being 25 to
Zer on the motion of marking House Bill
541 inexpedient to legislate I will
recommend the consent calendar for that
bill representative Emer thank you Mr
chairman House Bill 542 I recognize
representative pet3 and representative
he
okay Mr chair I move uh House Bill 542
itl and I will second house bill
542 motion a second to vote itl on House
Bill
542 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a rooll for the motion of
542 thank you Mr Mo uh Mr Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri VZ
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative Hull yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
camell yes representative papichi Muller
yes representative walner yes
representative norren yes representative
lman yes representative Buco yes
representative huitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
sh uh Shapiro yes representative hiin
Phillips yes represent Stringham
yes representative grassie yes and
representative wer yes Mr chair the vote
is 25 to0 to it House Bill 542
the vote being 25 to Zer on the motion
of inexpedient to legislate for House
Bill 542 I will recommend the consent
calendar representative
Emory thank you Mr chairman House Bill
546 relative to the school building aid
program uh imve itl uh the reason is
what the 546 does is it establishes 50
million net going for school building
Aid the current uh leg legis ation or in
the current budget allocates $50 million
which includes the tail or The Debt
Service so what 546 did was move the The
Debt Service out of the 50 million and
allow the full 50 million to go for
school aid building Aid in as much as it
was already in the budget at $50 million
for both I recommended I recommended
itl
second motion of in expedient to
legislate for House Bill
546 fnla FNL is there any further
discussion on the motion to inexpedient
to legislate seeing none the clerk will
call a rooll on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate for House Bill
546 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes represent Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofo yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative cose yes representative
papovich Muller yes Representative
walner
no Representative noren no
Representative leean no Representative
buo no Representative uitt
no representative Heath
no representative Murray no no
representative evil
no representative uh Shapiro
no representative haen Phillips
no representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 13 to2 to
itl
motion
546 House Bill 546 excuse me Mr chair I
just want to say that I will do a
Minority Report for that Minority Report
you motion of inexpedient to legislate
passes for House Bill 546 it will go on
the regular
calendar move cons question I move yes I
assume that you'll be recommending
OTP and by by the way I have some of
your reports already and as I said some
of the ones that are in expedience to
legislate where they were Incorporated
in the budget even if you don't give a
um a report today that's what it'll be
this this uh bill was unnecessary as it
was incorporated in
hp2 vote was X that that's the way it'll
go okay um representative Emory thank
you Mr chairman House Bill
560 I recognize representative
Petri thank you
uh I recommend HV 560 to uh make a
motion to itl
second the motion of inexpedient to
legislate for House Bill
560 has been made in seconded for
inexpedient to legisl is there any
further discussion seeing none the clerk
will call a role for the motion
inexpedient to legislate for House Bill
560 thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes represent Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
Campell yes representative Popich Muller
yes representative
walner
yes that I that was a that was yes yes
thank
you represent
norgran
yes representative leean yes
represent buo yes represent uitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative hen Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
wer
yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to Z to I
house Bill
560 the vote being 25 to Z on the motion
of inexpedient to legislate the house
bill 560 I will recommend that for the
consent calendar representative Emer
thank you Mr chairman House Bill 601
relative to State participation in the
Medicaid direct certification program
for free and reduced price School
meals I recognize representative po
M thank you I'd like to make a motion to
HB 601
FNL um having been both in the finance 2
committee Division and in the um joint
Senate house committee that looked at
the impact of um allowing direct
certification you know for medicate for
fnr I strongly believe that um this bill
needs to be ited the reasons are along
the following lines this has been argued
as an issue about Hunger kids not having
food in schools honestly I've at both
the committee with the Senate and also
uh I asked a direct question to New
Hampshire hanger Solutions during the
finance 2
presentation if they have any data on
kids actually not getting fed there is
no data there are no anecdotes now if
there is an issue the best way to look
at it is to look at the um seu having
launch debt we do not have state toide
data on that we did ask the doe during
the Finance to meeting to look for that
data and they said they will ask them
you know they will ask the school
districts about this and gather some
information we may be address able to
address this in the future the real
point of this bill is to change the way
uh you know State education funds are
distributed having been on the
budget process I know that we've already
increase the funding by 193 Millions
this year part of the funding was
allocated considering the fact that this
uh you know 7,000 something kids who may
be eligible are not enrolled in fnr I
think it would be unwise to um make a
change outside of the budget process I
believe that if this is a program that
needs to be discussed it should be
during the normal budget process so we
can make the necessary changes to the
education formula to make sure that the
funding is fair for everybody there have
also been concern is raised about the
privacy of the people involved in the
program and over the fact that they you
know need to have a choice to not be in
a program they may not want to be for
all those reasons I you know suggest
that the itl is the correct
outcome I second the motion I also make
the comment that um Medicare if the
person may be low income but they may
have good insurance from their employer
which would negate them being on Decay
so we can't assume that qualification
for one program is equal to the
qualification for the
other is there any further discussion on
601 seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call a rooll on
the motion of any expedient to legislate
for House Bill
601 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative Maguire yes yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
represent kofalt yes representative Bean
yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeny
yes representative Campell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative uh walner
no Representative norgan no
representative Lehman no representative
buo no Representative huitt
no representative Heath absolutely no
representative Murray
no represent evil no represent Shapiro
no representative hien Phillips no
representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
wer yes Mr chairman the vote is 13-
12 in favor of the
itl 6 and Mr chair there will be a
you
okay the uh in the vote being 13 to 12
House Bill 601 will be reported out as
inexpedient to legislate on the regular
calendar representative Emory thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 620 establishing
a division of early learning in the
Department of Education relative to pre
kindergarten pilot program
mil I would like to make a motion to um
itl second the motion is based on the
discussions we've had where we um
concluded or at least the majority
concluded that this would just not be
good policy that past attempts to
implement such programs did not result
in a measurable Improvement in the
outcome comes and therefore it is not um
you know necessary to um spend funds on
this Mr shair I like to comment
too memory because recognize yeah it
came out as part of the discussion uh
that this basically is Reinventing Head
Start uh and so if you if you look at
what headart did if you go to the Head
Start website they right on it it says
the program was ineffective so I
for that reason I support the
itl representative Heath thank you Mr
chair um House Bill 620 is a pilot
program for prek for children three and
four in public and Community settings my
request would be that we reconsider the
itl for an interim study thank you Mr
chair if it is defeated then you can we
can have an alternate motion the motion
before us at the present time is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
620 House Bill 620 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a rooll on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate the house bill
620 thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emerich yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofalt yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes represent Sweeney
yes representative camell yes represent
papovich Muller yes represent walner no
Representative noran no representative
Lehman no representative B
no Representative uitt
no representative Heath
no representative Murray no
representative eel no representative uh
Shiro no representative haen Phillips no
representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
wer yes Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12
of itl of
620 vot is 13 to 12 the motion of
inexpedient to legislate is adopted for
House Bill 620 it will go on the regular
calendar and there will be a minority
report for interim study thank you thank
you representative Emer thank you Mr
chairman House Bill 638 relative to the
extraordinary needs grants to schools uh
I'll make the motion for itl because in
the committee report uh we don't know
who made the motion so I'll make the
motion at this time since it's 9 to zero
I feel pretty comfortable with this one
I'll second that Mr chairman motion and
second to inexpedient to legislate for
House Bill 638 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role or the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
638 thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emerich yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofol yes repres Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeney yes
representative uh camell yes represent
Popovich Muller yes representative
walner
yes represent organ yes I'm sorry was
that okay thank
you Lehman yes represent buo yes
representative HT yes represent Heath
yes
yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
Shapiro yes representative haen
Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassy yes and representa wer yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to Z to I House
Bill
638 the vote being 25 to Zer the
recommendation will be itl House Bill
638 on the cons on the consent calendar
moving on to division three we'll call
Murray thank you uh division two and and
thank you for all your
workes on both sides of it I didn't do
anything both the recording and and the
motions and we try to keep it straight
representative
Marty Mooney thank you very much Mr
chairman I appreciate it I would move on
House Bill
itl first mistake
today okay is there a
second okay thank you Mr chairman I'd
like to speak to the motion if I could
on House Bill
91 so House Bill 91 relative to privacy
obligations of the Department of Health
and Human Services this bill creates a
data privacy and information technology
security governance board board within
the New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services in order to oversee
data privacy risk calculation and
mitigation this bill was incorporated in
House Bill 2 specifically section 79
colon 425 through 79 colon
427 it came out of division 3 with a 9
to Zer endorsement of itl I would ask
the committee to approve that motion
thank you thank you Motion in a second
for itl on House Bill for House Bill 91
is there any further discussion seeing
none the clerk will call a rooll on the
motion of any expedient to legislate on
House Bill 91 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Kofa yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeney yes representative camell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative walner yes representative
noren yes representative Lehman yes
represent buo yes representative HT yes
representative Heath
yes representative Murray yes
representative eel yes representative
Shapiro yes representative hien Phillips
yes representative
Stringham
yes represent grassy yes and
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 25 to Z to itl House Bill
91 the vote being 25 to Zer the
recommendation will be inexpedient to
legislate for House Bill 91 on the
consent talar Mr
yes although we just took this up I I
should have mentioned something before
in terms of the bill Maine had a data
breach this past summer it was announced
two days ago for the entire State
relative to
government contained data we need to be
really careful as a state in how we
manage our data I'm glad we did
something in the budget but there is
more to be
you put I did put on yes okay
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman I'm going to move House Bill 22
itl itl for motion for House Bill 282 is
there a second from division three
second second right by representative
Earth I can speak to that motion I
recognize House Bill 282 relative to
including certain children and pregnant
women in medic a and the children's
health insurance program this bill waves
the 5-year waiting period for Medicaid
and Chip coverage for children and
pregnant women lawfully residing in the
United States currently 35 other states
have waved this five-year weight for
lawful
immigrants this bill was included in
House Bill 2 passed and signed into law
on June 20th
2023 specifically within that bill
section 79 colon
412 the bill was endorsed itl by
division 39 to0 and I ask the committee
then to approve that motion thank
you motion of any expedience to
legislate has been made and seconded on
House Bill 282 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role for inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill
282 thank you Mr chairman represent
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
Popovich meller
yes representative walner
yes represent Oren yes representative
lman yes representative buo yes
representative huitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
Shapiro yes representative haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassie yes and representa Wilder yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to Z to itl H Bill
282 how the vote being 25 to Z we have
adopted the motion of any expedience to
legislate on House Bill 282 I will
recommend it for the consent calendar
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman I'm going to move on House Bill
527 itl and I'd like to speak to the
motion there a second
second you are recognized thank you Mr
chairman this bill House Bill 527
relative to Medicaid reimbursement rates
for certain Assisted Living facil
facilities now this bill would increase
the Medicaid reimbursement rates for
what's called certain small assisted
living facilities the bill asked for
$115 per day a difference from what it
$56.88 per
day uh this bill was incorporated in
House Bill 2 specifically section 79
colon
239 we got some clarification from when
division 3 met as to what these small
assisted living facilities would get now
per day from House Bill 2 and it ranges
between
$73 per day to about
$113 today depending on the code that
they fall into so they did receive a
very generous increase in the budget
passed earlier this year came out of
committee a 9 to zero with an
endorsement on itl so I'd ask this full
committee to adopt the motion as well
thank you Mr chair have a motion in a
second to Mark House Bill 527 is
inexpedient to legislate is there any
further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a rooll on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate House Bill
527 thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes
representative Maguire yes yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
represent kofalt yes representative Bean
yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cber yes representa
Popovich Muller yes representative
walner yes representative Oren yes
representative Lehman yes yes represent
buo yes represent hwit yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative eel yes
representative uh
Shapiro yes representative haen Phillips
yes represent Stringham yes represent
grassy yes represent wer yes Mr chair
the vote is 25 to Z to itl House Bill
527 vote being 25 to Z on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
527 that report is adopted and it will
be recommended for the consent calendar
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman I'm going to move on House Bill
565 itl and I'd like to speak to my
second Rec thank you Mr chair this bill
relative to expanding Medicaid to
include certain post postpartum healthc
care services so what this bill allows
and the end of the story is that this
bill is Incorporated in House Bill 2 but
what this bill allows is postpartum
health care services within Medicaid for
a full year as opposed to what was
currently a six-month period this
concept is now in-house Bill 2 signed
into law in June specifically section 79
colon
421 the itl motion came out of division
3 9 to0 and I'd ask the committee to
vote the same thank you Mr
chair a motion of inexpedient a second
and a second on House Bill
565 is there any further
on hacken Phillips okay just that us the
indication you want to say something but
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
of motion of in expedient to legislate
on House Bill 56 65 thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
uh Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofo yes representative
uh Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrell yes
representative papovich Muller yes
representative walner
yes representative norran yes
representative
leechman yes representative buo yes
representative uitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
Shapiro yes representative haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 25 to0 to I
House Bill
565 the vote being 25 to Z the
recommendation will be inexpedient to
legislate for House Bill 565 and request
the consent calendar representative
Mooney thank you Mr chair I'd like to
move House Bill 614 as itl and I'd like
motion a second motion and a second on
on uh House Bill
representative Mooney is recognized
thank you Mr chairman this bill is
relative to making an appropriation to
the Department of Health and Human
Services to fund the meramac New
Hampshire kidney cancer incidence phase
3 feasibility
study this bill was incorporated into
House Bill 2 earlier this year
specifically section 79 colon
429 now this bill appropriates funding
for a phase three feasibility study to
determine the effect effects of pasas
causing kidney cancer in the town of
miramac only two other New Hampshire
communities to in the past 10 years have
risen to the level of a phase three
study indicating the severity of the P
pollution on the human body specifically
my home Community miramac New Hampshire
I would ask that the full committee
uh vote for itl because again the town
of miramac is very grateful that it was
included in House Bill two in the Fe
phase three study will proceed because
of the budget earlier passed this year
thank you Mr
chair thank you motion of inexpedient to
legislate on a second on House Bill 614
is there any further discussion from
committee members seeing none the clerk
will call a rooll on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
614 64 thank you Mr Herman
representative F yes representative
Maguire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofalt yes representative Bean yes
representative pole yes representative
Sweeny yes representative camell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
representa walner
yes represent norburn yes repr lean yes
representative buo yes representative
uitt yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
eil yes representative Shapiro yes
representative hien Phillips yes
represent Stringham yes representative
uh grassy yes representative wer yes Mr
chair the vote is 25 to0 to itl host
Bill
614 the vote being 25 to Zer on the
motion of any meing to legislate the
house bill 614 it will be reported that
way and recommend for the consent
calendar representative Mooney thank you
Mr chairman on Senate Bill 239 if
representative Hull is ready to make a
motion for inim study then we can
entertain that
now sure relative to Senate Bill 239 um
the term harm reduction was not well
defined we had a lot of discussions on
it um this obviously needs additional
work I move in from study
I will second second by representative
kof fall Rec the motion is interim study
and I see representative Shapiro has
further comments thank you Mr chairman
um as previously noted um this is a
Senate bill that is meant to
codify um harm reduction that's already
being
um that's already exists and is being
provided for for in New Hampshire and
also to codify the provision of
substance misuse Services through the
doorways
program um when it initially came to
Health and Human Services there was
concern that
the definition of harm reduction was not
specific enough and it would open the
door to some kinds of harm reduction
activities that are done in other states
that we were not ready for here in New
Hampshire such as safe injection sites I
think um um the other kinds of harm
reductions that are already being done
here like needle
exchanges
um infectious disease
reduction overdose reversal through the
use of Nao Zone um are already happening
here so because of that concern that the
definition was not clear enough there
was a bipartisan effort to rewrite the
definition and a Floren was brought and
that amendment was passed 359 to 18 in
the full house um broad consensus that
that definition was narrow enough and
specific enough to allow for harm
reduction um that we were already doing
um but would not open the doors to
things that we did not want to see in
New Hampshire it was followed by a Voice
vote on the floor and
so this this bill if it was to pass
would not change anything that was being
done here already all these things are
already being done here um it would just
guarantee that they would be able to be
done into the future so I would ask that
we um vote no on the motion for interim
study so an alternative motion can be
made thank you representative cofal is
recognized thank you Mr chairman so
um as the person who actually brought
the floor amendment to clarify the um
the definition of harm
reduction I obviously voted for that
floor Amendment and I voted for the
original bill I think the fact that we
had such broad support for the original
bill or the the bill as Amendment
amended on the floor speaks to the fact
that there is Broad consensus that we
need to do things to reduce harm having
said that um I have subsequently learn
some new information about harm
reduction how that is interpreted in
other states and it gives me serious
concerns about the legislation even with
the clarifying amendment that we brought
I would like to see this bill move
forward I think that we need to continue
to um explore ways to implement harm
reduction in New
Hampshire however um the bill this bill
as it is right now
is is not ready for prime time I do not
feel comfortable with the definition of
harm reduction and therefore I believe
that a an interim study um interim study
is a is is the right path forward for
this Bill thank you represent hle thank
you Mr chairman having spent two years
of my life working at a drug and alcohol
rehab I have some
relevant understanding and experience in
this domain I'm not sure all the
proposed solutions that are part of harm
reduction address some of the underlying
mental health issues and environment
issues and social issues that drive
people to start using elicit
drugs um there are things that can be
done the bill does not address those I
think the best thing we can do is move
forward with actually putting some time
and effort into this to address those
who are abusing their lives their bodies
um via medications and um illegal drugs
and then start to reduce the number of
people who end up dying from some of
this any further discussion on a
question excuse me on uh Senate Bill
239 represent Petri yeah thank you Mr
chairman uh what's the different does
this mean the bill dies or why why can't
a the bill be reintroduced as a as a
different bill could you could someone
explain that we're still in the first
year of the the session so interim study
will come forward it can be uh taken up
next session and some decision made at
the end of the at the end of that
session for next
year but yeah 2025
2024 can't be brought
back2 stud this would be for 2025 it's
stud that's correct we're in the second
year of the session right now won be
until after until January so this is
gone for the next 12 months more than 12
thank
you all right so any further discussion
239 seeing none the clerk will call a
rooll on the motion of interim study for
Senate Bill
239 thank you Mr chairman representative
IR yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emerich yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
kofalt yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative camell yes
representative pich Muller yes
Representative walner
no Representative norgren no
Representative leichman no represent
Buco
no representative uitt
no representative Heath no
representative Murray no representative
eel
no representative uh um
chapiro
no representative haen Phillips no
representative Stringham no
Representative grassie no representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is
Report okay thank you uh the motion
being uh the vote being 13 to 12 on the
motion to inter study Senate Bill 239 it
will be so reported and recommended for
the regular
calendar representative Mooney thank you
Mr chairman uh as for Senate Bill
263 I would recognize representative
ready he was born
wait uh Senate Billet uh 263 I recommend
itl and like to speak to my motion May
recogn and the second was representative
po or
Moone it's fine either
one
so s
sp263 in its
entirety is included
exactly in
hb2 with one exception and only one
exception and I think there are five
parts I'm not mistaken to the to the
bill the one exception is the term of
the extension of Medicaid expansion or
the granted Advantage Program in hb2 as
we passed it that's a 7-year extension
in Sp sp263 that's before us it's it
makes it
permanent at this point I there's a
variety of reasons I think it's a
mistake to make it permanent but one of
them is we don't really have a clear
idea of the costs of the program so this
program began uh 5 years ago I believe
um and during that time it's gone up in
cost which is not unexpected but more
than that we had coid which drove up the
cost substantially because a state of
emergency was declared and then based on
that
declaration a what do they call those
things they do the
executive order thank you Mar Jan was uh
done that prevented States from removing
people from the Medicaid Program and the
Medicaid expansion program so what that
meant was somebody who might be on might
qualify for Medicaid in a single month
wound up being on there for a number of
years and that time period did not even
lapse at the point when the president
indicated that Co was really a thing of
the past the the extension the emergency
was allowed to extend beyond that time
so now people have started coming off
that began earlier um this year so the
price the the cost will start going back
down again but what that tells us is we
not much we don't really have a clear
understanding of where this program is
going and I have a further issue with
this program with the granted Advantage
Program in particular because as many
people are not aware it is not on the
budget so it's not easy for any of us to
find out what the actual cost of the
program is or in fact even how it's
funded and while we the house did try to
in the budget uh put it require that it
be put onto the budget in hb2 the Senate
stripped that out in the version of the
budget which is what um
which is what we passed uh in the
spring so two things you know one the
fact that we don't have a great track
record now to to look at but two going
forward is very clear that with a simple
Declaration of the state of emergency
which doesn't require any laws being
passed by Congress the executive branch
can then turn around and say well we're
not going to let anybody come off with
Medicaid again at some point in the
future in other words they can change
the program without our having um any
impact on that without Congress having
any impact on that and that will drive
up our costs in dependent of anything
that we're doing other than having to
pass another law at that point in time
so for that for those reasons um I
recommend that we um kill this so that
we have our seven-year extension as or
our seven-year extension as in current
law and we can revisit this in at at the
end of that time frame thank you further
discussion I see some lights on
representative
Stringham thank you Mr chair for the
past eight years Medicaid expansion has
provided Primary Care preventative
Services and Specialty Care to
low-income residents and workers
contributing to the healthier Workforce
while reducing uncompensated care and
thereby reducing insurance rates in the
individual Market s
sp263 received strong support from the
business and medical community upon its
introduction in the Senate and passed on
the that body on a unanimous bipartisan
vote the house voted 193 to 166 to pass
this legislation on May 18th and it was
subsequently referred to the finance
committee and
retained following its retention in
house finance uh the seven-year
extension of gr estate Advantage was
enacted as part of hb2 as my esteemed
colleague mentioned uh therefore the
fiscal impact of this legislation is
already accounted for in the state
budget
sb263 is sound policy and should again
pass the house while the extension
enacted in hb2 provide short-term
stability by enabling the state to
negotiate five-year contracts with
Managed Care organizations it does not
provide the long-term stability required
to meet the medical needs of granted
Staters removing the sunset would allow
the providers to build infrastructure
and provide the workforce necessary to
uh meet our state's needs improving the
quality of care for everyone getting rid
of the sunset doesn't do anything to
address the other still can be addressed
the other issues that my colleague
mentioned as well so I ask everyone to
vote no on the itl motion so that an
autop pass motion that the house senate
business community and medical community
supported can be voted on thanks
representative Griffin you have your
light
on and input representa
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman I would
just like to add
that
when house Senate Bill 263 came to the
house the first time um before it was
sent to the finance committee there were
many many amendments that came up for a
vote the first amendment that came up
for a vote was to limit
the extension for six years almost
identical to what eventually happened in
the budget and um believe me I was happy
that it came out seven years in the
budget um so when the amendment to limit
it to six years came up in the house it
was voted down so I just wanted to make
it clear that we've already visited this
issue of the amount of time of the
extension and the house position was
to vote down limiting it to six years
and keeping it is permanent and I would
just um along with my colleague uh urge
you to vote this down um so that we can
make Medicaid expansion permanent thank
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a role on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on Senate Bill 263
FN thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes represent Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative kofol yes representative
Bean yes representative hle yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
camell yes representative papichi Muller
yes Representative walner no
Representative norren
no representative Lehman yes
yes
[Laughter]
sorry hey that's all right I hadn't I
didn't write it down you're you're
covered you're covered uh Representative
buo
no represent uitt
no representative Heath no
representative Murray no representative
evil no representative Shapiro no
represent haen Phillips no represent
Stringham no Representative grassie no
representative Wier yes Mr chair the
vote is 13-2 to itl Senate Bill
263 motion there motion Minority
Report the vote being 13- 12 the
recommendation is inexpedient to
legislate on Senate Bill 263 FN it will
go on the regular calend calendar the
reports for those of you that made the
Motions are due today uh they'll have to
go and thank you representative eel has
already turned them in
um and and I think one of yours is going
to be used as a Minority
Report okay sorry I didn't mention that
earlier I know we'd have that discussion
and we' work that out I appreciate the
efficiency of all the committee and and
our our newly added members that I
appreciate you being here to fill in um
thank you all for your work and uh we'll
see you on
the on the floor the next time we meet
so we'll have we'll have our reports
ready and they will go forward and I
thank you all for your attendance and
your uh
work